[Música]
cerca de 3000 personas han sido
evacuadas de las inmediaciones del río
nieper después del colapso de la presa
de Jacob un incidente que afecta tanto a
la orilla occidental controlada por
Ucrania como a la Oriental en manos de
Rusia kiev habla de una catástrofe
ambiental mientras Vladimir Putin tilda
como un acto bárbaro Y lo atribuye a los
ucranianos
se instala en Chile el consejo
constitucional conformado por 50
miembros electos y donde la derecha y la
extrema derecha tienen mayoría el
consejo tiene cinco meses para entregar
una nueva Carta Magna que se someterá a
referendo en diciembre conectamos con
Santiago
este miércoles el Papa Francisco pasa
nuevamente por el quirófano para una
cirugía abdominal ante el riesgo de una
obstrucción intestinal el papa se había
sometido ayer a una serie de exámenes y
pasará unos días en el hospital gemeli
de Roma Tenemos reporte
Buenos días Bienvenidos a las noticias
de France 24 en español Soy Rosa Pérez
más deu y es para mí un gusto
acompañarles abrimos esta edición con
información de la guerra en Ucrania
Porque tanto kiev como Moscú avanzan en
las evacuaciones de miles de personas en
las inmediaciones del río nieper
inundadas tras la destrucción de la
presa de kahoofka en gerson la autoría
del incidente permanece incierta de
hecho
Moscú culpa a Estados Unidos y a los
aliados occidentales de kiev de
autorizar el ataque mientras el
presidente de Turquía recepta hiperdogán
propuso a bolodimirdsky constituir una
investigación internacional el
presidente ruso calificó el hecho como
un acto bárbaro cometido por Ucrania
amal Ben ozman tiene el informe
niños cargados a hombros y lo que queda
de las pertenencias en unas cuantas
bolsas plásticas así avanza la
evacuación de miles de civiles en la
región de gersón tras la destrucción de
La Represa de kahovka equipados con
pequeñas lanchas neumáticas estos
soldados ucranianos ayudan con las
labores en uno de los distritos
inundados según las autoridades
ucranianas el nivel del agua ha subido
3,5 metros en algunas partes de gersón y
más de 40.000 personas están en zona de
riesgo y cientos de miles han quedado
sin acceso a agua potable
nos inundamos hasta aquí No sé todo está
sumergido en el agua todos los muebles
la nevera la comida todas las flores
todo está flotando no sé qué hacer unas
decenas de kilómetros más arriba del Río
niefer en zonas controladas por las
autoridades rusas las evacuaciones
también han comenzado
Moscú y kiev se culpan mutuamente del
ataque a la presa y la destrucción de la
central hidroeléctrica el presidente de
ucraniano acusó a Rusia de detonar una
bomba medioambiental
el mundo entero conocerá este crimen de
guerra ruso El crimen de ecocidio esta
destrucción deliberada por parte de los
ocupantes rusos de la presa y otras
estructuras de la central hidroeléctrica
de cajoca es una bomba medioambiental de
destrucción masiva y en una reunión de
la ONU el martes Rusia habló de Sabotaje
por parte de kiev El Sabotaje deliberado
llevado a cabo por kiev contra una
instalación de infraestructura crítica
es extremadamente peligroso y puede
clasificarse esencialmente como crimen
de guerra o acto de terrorismo los
expertos por su parte describen una
catástrofe cuyas consecuencias se
sentirán durante décadas y que será de
Gran alcance para ambas partes en la
línea de frente
en otras noticias el secretario de
estado de Estados Unidos Anthony blinken
se reunió Este miércoles con el príncipe
heredero saudí Bin salman y destacó que
la relación entre ambos países se basa
en el progreso en protección de los
derechos humanos y en la agenda de la
reunión figura la posible normalización
de relaciones entre Arabia Saudita e
Israel y el encuentro llega después
recordemos de que reatie Washington
hayan cooperado en la mediación de
treguas en Sudán sin embargo también en
medio de roces sobre las relaciones con
Irán y la reciente decisión de riat de
reducir su producción de crudo para
aumentar el precio del petróleo
vamos con información ahora de América
Latina porque en chile se instala hoy en
esta jornada el consejo constitucional
formado por 50 miembros elegidos el
pasado 7 de mayo en las urnas que
tendrán a partir de ahora cinco meses
para entregar una nueva propuesta de
Carta Magna al país en un segundo
intento recordemos después de que en
septiembre pasado los chilenos
rechazarán masivamente una primera
propuesta de reemplazar la Constitución
de La dictadura de Augusto pinochet en
la ceremonia de este miércoles
participan representantes de los tres
poderes del estado y el presidente
Gabriel borch y nuestra corresponsal
Patricia Luna se encuentra Precisamente
en la sede donde va a trabajar el
consejo constitucional Patricia Buenos
días para usted le pregunto Cuáles son
las diferencias entre este proceso
constitucional que arranca ahora y el
anterior
Hola pues como bien has dicho nos
encontramos en la sede del excongreso
nacional y también en esta jornada se
escuchan manifestaciones A los
alrededores estas serían algunas de las
similitudes de un proceso constitucional
muy diferente a la anterior impartimos
por ejemplo por el número de miembros
son 50 los consejeros constitucionales
uno de ellos representante de las
comunidades indígenas frente a los 155
miembros del proceso anterior Donde
había 17 escaños reservados a los
pueblos indígenas además la jornada van
a recibir un anteproyecto de texto
constitucional elaborado por una
comisión de expertos de 24 miembros 12
de ellos elegidos por la cámara de
diputados y 12 del senado y habrá unas
doce bases constitucionales en las que
se tienen que regir esta este consejo
constitucional no es la carta blanca de
la que partía el proceso anterior además
como señalabas en la ceremonia están
presentes los tres representantes de los
poderes del Estado algo que no ocurría
en el proceso anterior en el que también
había un intento más de que el pueblo
estuviera representado de esta forma se
inicia este consejo constitucional este
miércoles aquí en Santiago Patricia como
usted decía Esta es la segunda
oportunidad pero es también la última
oportunidad de los chilenos para
reformar esta Constitución heredada de
Augusto pinochet
pues así sería según lo expresado por el
presidente Gabriel boric en una
entrevista Televisa un canal local esta
semana en la que firmaba que al menos
por su parte en su gobierno no va a
haber un nuevo intento de proceso
constitucional es una incógnita lo que
va a pasar el presidente se manifestó a
favor del texto elaborado por el
anteproyecto elaborado por el comité de
expertos sin embargo muchos de los
integrantes del Consejo constitucional
entre ellos la mayoría de ultraderecha
ya ha manifestado algunas diferencias
respecto a este anteproyecto que
establece por ejemplo a Chile como un
estado social democrático y de derechos
un cambio significativo frente al Estado
subsidiario de la Constitución actual
Parece que esta sería por tanto el
intento definitivo veremos qué es lo que
pasa en los próximos cinco meses hasta
noviembre en un proceso también en el
que va a participar la ciudadanía en
esta jornada se abre el plazo también
para que
los ciudadanos puedan presentar sus
propuestas Durante un mes a través de
una canalización de las universidades en
algo que también marca una diferencia
con el proceso anterior veremos qué pasa
en el plebiscito de salida del próximo
diciembre Pues sí Patricia iremos a
sillón de todo este este proceso Muchas
gracias por este reporte
nosotros cambiamos de tema y vamos a
Italia porque el papá Francisco se
encuentra ya en el hospital gemeli de
Roma donde será sometido a una nueva
cirugía bajo anestesia general según
informó El Vaticano el máximo líder de
la Iglesia Católica padece una hernia
abdominal que amenaza con generar una
obstrucción intestinal nos amplía
nuestra corresponsal Natalia Mendoza
fue a través de un corto comunicado que
el Vaticano confirmó que el sumo
pontífice ha sido admitido en un
hospital Romano para ser operado en la
tarde de este miércoles el papa será
sometido a una laparotomía y a una
cirugía plástica de la pared abdominal
con prótesis una intervención quirúrgica
necesaria dice el Vaticano a causa de un
riesgo de obstrucción intestinal el
comunicado indica que Francisco sufre de
una hernia incisional encarcelada que
está provocando síndromes oclusivos
recurrentes dolorosos y que empeoran la
operación se desarrollará bajo anestesia
general el papa deberá permanecer
hospitalizado durante varios días
después de esta operación Este no es el
primer problema de salud del papa de 86
años en julio de 2021 fue operado de un
problema en el colon los médicos le
retiraron treinta y tres centímetros de
intestino y en marzo de este año estuvo
tres noches en el hospital por una
pulmonía aguda el papa también sufre de
problemas en su rodilla derecha que le
obligan a caminar con un bastón o en
silla de ruedas
cambiamos de noticia porque la Unión
Europea quiere reforzar las relaciones
con América Latina donde tanto Rusia
como china aumentan su influencia y el
equipo del jefe de la diplomacia europea
josep purell elaboró una hoja de ruta
para lograr este objetivo nuestra
corresponsal en Bruselas Esther Herrera
nos tiene los detalles
la Unión Europea está Ahora más que
nunca decidida a revitalizar las
relaciones con América Latina y con los
países del Caribe y esto explica esta
comunicación presentada hoy por parte de
la comisión europea a Bruselas que
quiere apostar porque 2023 sea el año en
que se puedan revitalizar estas
relaciones entre ambos bloques y para
empezar considera que la relación entre
la Unión Europea y los países de la
comunidad de Estados latinoamericanos y
caribeños debe ser de carácter
permanente por lo tanto pide por ejemplo
que haya reuniones de carácter
permanente cada dos años entre que se
puedan alternar entre reuniones de
cancilleres y de jefes de estado y de
gobierno el objetivo es acabar con casos
como el actual por ejemplo en que hace
ya ocho años en que no se celebra una
reunión de alto nivel entre la Unión
Europea y los países de la celac el jefe
de la diplomacia europea es admitido que
ambas regiones en los años han vivido de
espaldas una a la otra a pesar de ser
socios naturales pero lo que se quiere
apostar es pasar de ser socios naturales
a ser socios por elección y por ello se
habla de fortalecer también las
relaciones comerciales apostar por los
acuerdos comerciales por ejemplo con el
bloque de mercosur un acuerdo que se
cerró por ejemplo en 2019 pero que ahora
mismo faltará un cuestiones técnicas
está a la espera de contrapropuestas por
parte de los países del mercosur para
apostar también por en contra de la
deforestación y apostar a favor del
medio ambiente también el acuerdo con
chile recientemente firmado que en que
se apuesta también por materiales
críticos Como por ejemplo el litio y
también el acuerdo con México que
también falta firmar por todo ello la
Unión Europea también quiere también
fortalecer la inversión muy importante a
través de su plan de inversiones el
conocido como global Gateway también
para hacer frente a la conocida como
ruta de la seda China
y vamos ahora a Estados Unidos donde
crece la preocupación por el humo que
llega de los incendios forestales de
Canadá Incluso el alcalde de Nueva York
pidió a los civiles con problemas
respiratorios que eviten salir de sus
casas Ramiro cueva verena tiene el
informe
el impacto ambiental de los incendios en
Canadá ha cruzado la frontera y ha
llegado hasta Estados Unidos donde el
viento ha llevado a la contaminación del
humo y el aire empieza a verse afectado
en grandes ciudades como Nueva York
Incluso el alcalde neoyorquino Erick
Adams pidió a los ciudadanos que
extremen las precauciones
si usted es un neoyorquino con problemas
cardíacos o respiratorios tenga cuidado
cuando esté al aire libre el humo de los
incendios forestales de Canadá está
afectando al aire de nuestra ciudad por
lo que se ha emitido un aviso sanitario
sobre la calidad del aire intenta
limitar hoy las actividades al aire
libre a lo estrictamente necesario
durante el martes la agencia de
protección ambiental emitió una alerta
por la mala calidad del aire en nueva
Inglaterra sumándose a las advertencias
de Illinois Wisconsin y Minnesota la
propagación de las partículas se está
registrando no solo por el aire sino
también por el agua a través del río
Ohio lo que ha elevado a la preocupación
de los expertos sobre el nivel de
contaminación de la afluente los niveles
que estamos hoy en día son Realmente
mucho más altos de lo que normalmente se
ve en una gran ciudad contaminada de
Asia por ejemplo
desafortunadamente es probable que estos
niveles se mantengan altos hasta que se
apaguen los incendios en Canadá el
panorama para sofocar el fuego no es
alentador solamente en la provincia de
Quebec hay más de 150 focos activos en
una temporada que ya registrado 422
incendios y
226.084 hectáreas dañadas en lo que va
del año
y cerramos con las noticias que nos deja
ya el Roland garros el segundo Grand
slam del año donde ya se conocen los
nombres de las semifinalistas
Beatriz hadat Maya eliminó a la tunecina
onceberg y se convirtió en la primera
brasileña en clasificar a semifinales
del torneo parisino en La Era abierta
cayó en el primer set por tres a seis
pero remontó los dos siguientes ganando
por tyrek en el segundo y cerrando con
un contundente seis a uno en el tercero
su rival será la polaca y garcíatec
número uno del mundo que eliminó en dos
sets a la estadounidense cocogoff por
6-4 y 62
[Aplausos]
veamos así al final de esta edición
informativa pero recuerden que pueden
ampliar estas noticias y muchos más en
nuestras redes sociales y en nuestra
página web France 24.com enseguida
volvemos
[Música]